[Music]
celebrating the holidays always makes me
think about a ton of people piled in the
kitchen laughing eating and that's what
i love the most
hi i'm ellen bennett the founder and ceo
of hedley and bennett and today we're
making chilaquiles frittata and dia's
mexican poncho i'm half mexican and half
english so i grew up always eating these
delicious beautiful colorful meals in
mexico buncha makes me think of the
holidays it smells like the holidays it
tastes like the holidays it's fun like
the holidays i love seeing my aunts and
uncles sticking their hands into their
cups and just chewing on the sugar cane
and everybody just becomes like little
kids and every day that you heat it up
one more time they get more and more
gooey and it just gets better while i've
let my bunches start going it's going to
take about 30 minutes i'm gonna run over
and start making the chilaquiles
frittata if you have any eggshells fall
in there which don't even worry about it
happens to the best of us you just scoop
it out with half of an eggshell and it
comes right out it's kind of amazing the
inspiration behind my chilaquiles
frittata is that i have six chickens at
home and they always make tons and tons
of eggs for us anytime i have people
over i just whip up a quick frittata and
i like to have some crunch in it so i
decided why don't i combine my frittata
with chilaquiles i like to start my
frittata with olive oil and butter which
are just the greatest flavors of all
time and they make food so beautiful
creamy and nice and spongy frittata is
basically a quiche without a crust and
chilaquiles is essentially a bunch of
tortilla chips that you pour tons of
salsa cheese cream onion cilantro on top
of and it's a delicious breakfast that's
super super old school in mexico so i
combined them and made a new dish called
chilaquiles frittata take a little
spatula and start to help it come off
the sides so that it can get a little
bit of air ventilation going on you have
something super fluffy and light
combined with a crunchy surprise from
your tortilla chips
making pancetta is so much fun and such
a good party trick because you can throw
it on the stove while you're making
everything else and before you know it
it's completely ready to go and it makes
your entire house smell delicious i
always love to throw down butcher paper
on the table because a it kind of serves
like a tablecloth and b it helps protect
your table from 800 people piling into
your house you get to just write on the
actual table and then people know what
they're eating what they need the
garnish for if they want to smash up the
salsa anymore they can take the salsa
smasher and they can go to town making
people feel comfortable sometimes can be
hard and when everything is too perfect
people get nervous they don't want to
mess anything up so laying out all the
food on a table like this just makes it
feel warm and cozy while still adding to
the style of the table your food and
your garnishes are functioning as color
and elements that just make it look
better anyway great for instagram great
for an overhead shot and great for your
belly i wish you guys could smell this
right now it is so good i hope you guys
feel super inspired to throw a little
holiday party together make it a brunch
make it easy now i hope you get out
there in the world and cook up something
magical in the kitchen too there's so
much fun things to be done it's only a
matter of getting yourself in there and
making it happen
[Music]
oh yes
you